[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life
about your money about your work your
purpose your relationships your family
your marriage your children uh it's the
whole enchilada because this life is
full and we want to give you hope with
practical solutions and steps for you to
take so that you can be
and do what you
are supposed to be doing triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number i'm ken coleman ramsey
personality and i'm joined by my
colleague also ramsey personality dr
john deloney and we are here together to
take your questions so i just gave you
the gamut bottom line is
we are here for you
we want to talk to you and today may be
a day where you have some breakthrough
where you feel safe to just call in
you know i point this out on my show
john i don't know if you do this on
yours but you know we routinely on the
ken coleman show change people's name
and location because of the sensitivity
you're talking about change your career
talking about a toxic boss or co-worker
you're talking about extremely sensitive
stuff in the mental and emotional state
relationships so i i want to point that
out kelly will do that and and you know
i i pointed out on my show a good bit
because we want people to feel the
safety we'll change the location
your name the whole nine yards john and
i won't know anyway absolutely we just
call out what's on the board i got a
note from somebody on instagram recently
saying hey thanks for taking my call
and i didn't recognize the name at all
and then in parentheses they said by the
way i was rick and i was like
yeah so man yeah just we'll disguise
anything we want to keep you safe and
i'll give you an opportunity to be open
and vulnerable and we can get down to it
man that's it so let's do it jeffrey
starts us off today in austin texas
jeffrey how can we help
hey ken uh thanks for taking my call um
so yesterday i took the career
assessment test i've been in the same
role for about five years here
um i'm not looking to start over into
like an entry level um into a totally
new field
but you know some of the positions i'm
interested in i'll have applicable
knowledge and skills but i've never
worked exactly in that role so my
question is how do i take my past
working experience on my resume and
pitch myself into a related career path
but that's not necessarily on the same
side of the same fence yeah well i i
think it's a really good question but i
think you're just overthinking it and so
when we overthink and i got the doc here
next to me he'll add some actual
scientific stuff to what i'm about to
say this is good old-fashioned common
sense when i overthink i know that i've
got to then withdraw from all of the
analysis and just go back to what i know
to be true so i'm just going to put it
to you this way when you look at that
position or positions that you're
talking about that you've just
referenced do you have the talent to do
the work yes or no
i believe so come on i want you to say
that differently i'm going to give you a
chance i'm going to retest you on that
one do you have the talent jeffrey
to perform that role and perform it well
absolutely there we go yes i like that i
was hoping for an absolute freaking
lully but i'll take absolutely we'll
give that an a minus
all right
so the experience that you have
while you don't have a ton of experience
in those roles you're looking at
are there
elements
of the experience you do have that are
going to allow you to jump in and
quickly get up to speed and learn yes or
no
absolutely yeah all right then we're
done
conversation over brother yeah i mean i
hate to be so simple but dude you've got
this and by the way
the reason i ask those simple questions
like that and john i want you to come in
here and give the scientific you know
counseling approach to this but jeffrey
the reason i ask you those questions i
think you just need to remind yourself
of that on a regular basis and by the
way you're not there's nothing wrong
with you or abnormal i mean this is kind
of normal human condition stuff but i
need to remind myself of the facts
and you're feeling sometimes
uh you know don't represent the facts
let's get the facts and i think the
feelings will follow in this situation
so when you present yourself from the
moment you apply to the moment you're in
the interview you're ready you got an
answer for it because then you can say
well this past experience
here's how this translates and remember
you're in an interview where they're
just simply trying to determine one
thing
can you help them win
yeah can you can you help them make
money and will you be someone who's not
an idiot to be around i think we also
get hung up on job titles we see people
who have title of assistant vice
president or assistant whatever and we
think man they are like fill in the
blank not us
stand up tall there is some a lot of
psychology about standing up tall about
potty posture about looking yourself in
the mirror picking your chin up and
acknowledging i can do this job don't
lie to yourself don't lie to people but
acknowledge i can do this job and here's
something else ken i think is important
it may be that
i don't have direct experience in this
particular skill
but i do have peripheral experience it
proves that i can learn this very
quickly 100 and i will walk alongside
you so sometimes it might be have you
done this thing versus man they're close
or i've proven i can learn this then you
bring that with your with your with your
spine straight and your chin up you
bring that kind of attitude to um to the
interview yeah it's exactly right you
know everything to me
at this time of year with football all
over the place i love football
you know
if you were on special teams and a lot
of guys get in the nfl john just by
playing special teams you know they're
not playing first-team defense or
offenses of the way they get in they
make the 53-man roster by simply being
the guy who's willing to run down the
field like a kamikaze pilot and just
crush the other ball carrier well these
guys all want to play another position
some of them want to be on offense some
of them want to be on defense and
they're trying to convince that coach
just like jeffrey's trying to convince a
potential employer that while i have it
started before in this role i do know
how to tackle coach
and i can learn how to read the defense
in the linebacker position
that's the idea dude that's a great
analogy because i'm also going to show
you in practice i'm going to work my
butt off in practice i'm gonna show you
and then when i get put on the field in
whatever weird situation
i'm gonna run a hundred miles an hour
towards that guy yeah and
i may not make that big dif big
difference to ending the income the end
of the game but that guy tomorrow's
gonna remember me cause he's gonna have
my number tattooed across well who's the
coach gonna call when the starter goes
down that's exactly right the first name
that pops up and so this stay with us in
this analogy folks because there's some
broad teaching here
when we transfer and we move and we
pivot and we got a
billion americans thinking about doing
that right now
the transferable skill and experience
does in fact transfer show them the
application and just like that football
player that wants to go from being a
special teams player to starting free
safety you're gonna show them that you
can learn that you're coachable yeah
that you got all the raw stuff
and in this world john increasingly
companies are doing all the training
themselves yes
show them you know how to fight and
you've got grit yeah you will show up so
yes and so here's why i make that point
john don't assume
that you got to show up day one ready to
go
they're gonna train you they're gonna
train you how to do it they how they
want it done anyway right yeah hey let
me ask you a question so over the course
of my career i've hired a bajillion
employees but most of them were new
employees this is their first
professional job or maybe their second
professional job
they are now five years 10 years later
some of them 15 years later circling
back and they are applying for
leadership positions they've been
working up to their career
i am getting an overwhelming amount of
calls from former colleagues that are
frenzied i got to move i got to do this
i've been here one year i got to move to
this thing what would you tell folks who
are just feeling this panic and frenzy i
gotta go i gotta go gotta go no i would
say that opportunity is not fleeting
that's opportunity's gonna be there if
it's not a burning heart desire
to really move and if it's not the right
move to keep you going on the path and
it moves you faster chill out chill out
we're on the path man i'll start using
breathe a little chill out chill out
opportunities aren't just fleeting the
dream is gonna be there i promise all
right folks don't go anywhere he is dr
john deloney i am ken coleman and this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to feartalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show america
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
dolone we're taking your calls triple
eight eight two five
five two two five it is a free number
triple eight eight two five
five two two five here at ramsey
solutions we are on a mission not just
on this show but through our entire
company to transform
lives
and we want to disrupt the culture
in the money culture the work culture
relationship culture and
we know that that's not normal but we
want you for a moment just to imagine
being a part of this team
a team that's on a mission to make all
of that disruption a reality through
doing work every day at ramsey solutions
we have a thousand people working
together to create digital products and
services that will transform people's
lives if you want to join us on that
crusade we are on the hunt
for software engineers with expertise in
ruby on rails java
c-sharp and front-end technologies or if
you're a ux designer seo or content
marketing specialist we'd love to talk
with you find out about all the
available jobs by texting work to 33789
text the word work to
33789 to find out about all of our open
opportunities and i would point out
if you go to kencoleman.com and download
the free resume guide and use that
template hr looks at you a little bit
closer that is an absolute fact so
there's a little extra tip i didn't know
that well it's a ramsey solutions
resource and they see that and they go
oh
they pay attention to what's going on
yeah it's just a little tip i like it
not getting it not guaranteeing you
anything i think what i just heard is
ken coleman said if you use that resume
guys you'll get the job you've got the
job now that would be false advertising
i did not say that so uh but but i do
think it'll get you some special
attention and then you gotta earn it on
your own so i like it just a little tip
there triple eight eight two five five
two two five john joins us in amarillo
texas john how can we help by morning
hello john how are you doing guys great
doing great what's going on
so having an
issue or not really an issue but hey
john can you talk into your phone for us
talk directly on that phone there
yes for just a second okay
okay is that better excellent there we
go
so
wife and i were discussing how much we
should be spending on our grocery budget
while we're in baby step two
and it's been fluctuating the last few
months between 250 to
300 just depending
uh upon the week
but that's for
a household of four
is that about right what's your take on
what's your take-home pay
uh so
weekly i i take home about uh
2 000 2100 somewhere in there yeah
well i i don't know that there's any
normal percentage on this but i mean
how's the family doing are the kids
getting skinnier i mean what are we what
are we doing here are they are they
struggling are we not having any food
no i think we've actually got plenty i
actually think we could scale back a
little more and that's what i thought
that was my question is is should we
should we try to
swing the budget down a little bit more
i mean we're on track to be completely
debt free
in about four months oh yeah
what's the one
time
john is this 250 bucks a month or a week
no two thousand
two thousand dollars a week no no no no
groceries
on groceries uh roughly about 200 to 250
a week
a week okay i was thinking a month i
thought the way you said it i thought it
was a month and i was like man that's
why i thought the kids were getting
skinny dude okay so about 800 bucks a
month yeah i definitely think you guys
can cut from that but you said you and
the wife were talking about it
she doesn't want to cut right
so we we've kind of talked about it and
where the deal is
both of us are on board to cut back
if we need to
but
right now with what we're spending
we're on track to be debt free in four
months so yeah so you're behind that is
a big issue so what's the heart behind
the call is it
is it a disagreement on
food values you want to buy organic
foods and you don't and you don't want
to
or you're not cutting back on something
so she didn't want to come back what's
the heart of this question
the
big part of it is
should we cut back a little more to get
out of debt maybe a month sooner than
what
we're anticipating currently
well my answer to that is why not i mean
but i don't think there's a wrong answer
here we're talking about being debt free
in three months versus four months and
we're talking about this is about the
amount of nachos and hot dogs we buy i
mean i don't know i mean i think it gets
down to er you know i don't know you
have two seniors in high school who are
six foot eleven and yeah they eat raw
meat every i mean or
you got
new kids yeah like ken you're right i
just don't think there's a wrong answer
john congratulations man you're four
months away from being debt free and
you're calling us about your grocery
budget look dude i say make the call and
i would go with what mama wants i've
been married 23 and a half years that's
where i'm leaning on this particular one
yeah mama wants a little extra on the
cupboard i'm gonna go okay dear
and if you guys are on track to do this
like by the new year right so i mean
there's not a way to lose here the only
way to lose here is to fight over
something that's not worth fighting over
yeah and i got to tell you this is not
working no no no not not here
congratulations yeah that's awesome yeah
i love it now that's a gazelle intensity
john yeah it's like
well uh we're uh debt-free in four
months but uh if we really cut our
grocery button we don't eat in october
we could have this done in november yeah
it's like we don't have to do that good
job there i love it i'd go you know what
i'd i'd keep buying the steak and make
sure we did something real special
grill out when we paid it i do like this
though i like the
we're going to go through every line in
this budget yes when you step back and
look at a family of four and say our
groceries eight hundred dollars a month
that's a lot
and what are we buying how are we buying
where are we buying it from what stores
what you know what food are we anyway
you can go down those lists and i do
love that you're four months out man
four months out and i got two teenage
boys i got a 13 and 15. can i just tell
you something
when i walk up to the carts at costco
there's like a big sound of trumpet
blows and they go welcome
coleman's
i mean the amount of eggs and i just saw
today a headline that the cost of bacon
is going up and i thought now this is
the sign of the apocalypse we we like to
be hopeful here at ramsey solutions we
always believe control which you could
but the price of bacon is going up i
mean this is when we've got to do
something
i've got a sixth grader and we're we're
backing trucks up to the house i don't
understand where it goes oh he's got a
hollow leg yes and it's oh by the way as
he gets older it's only going to get
worse imagine having two of those i
can't i can't wrap my head around that
financially yeah i cook the food at the
house and as quickly as i cook it it's
gone
i told stacey i would like to at least
put a little moratorium like can it sit
on the table for fun
maybe i could take a picture and
document that you know what i think
that's where instagram of photos of food
started it was just a poor parent saying
hey hey hey i just i want to document
that it's so true before my children
inhale it through one of their nostrils
oh my gosh that is so true i love it all
right blinds.com 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color which would be
me by the way they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best deal
all right today's question comes from
chad in california i'm 19 i've never
been a good student i was more
interested in making money
and helping others i have an e-commerce
business that took off this year i've
made a hundred and three thousand
dollars in profit live with my parents
and they think i'm going to community
college i'm scared they'll kick me out
if they find out the truth should i
continue pursuing my business venture or
go back to school and have the safety
net of being able to live at home if i
choose the business route i won't have
the financial safety of living with my
parents anymore good grief john
okay this is really more your angle it's
not so much onion here i would do the
business but i'd be a man and talk to
mommy my 11 year old would solve this
tell the truth to your parents you're
making six figures they're not gonna
kick you out no you sure if they do you
should be anyway yes
goodness gracious chad this you've made
this way too complicated this is a
19 year old question be honest with your
parents tell them that you're making six
figures congratulations and if they kick
you out with an apartment you can afford
it for the next decade
it's kind of humorous now that we've
answered it this is next level deception
my parents think i'm going to community
college but i'm in real life toby
mcguire spiderman i'm more money
building a business on the side
dude what are you hiding from
wow appreciate the question talk to mom
and dad all right folks don't move
he's john delaney i'm ken coleman and
you're listening to the ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney we are coming to you from our
nashville headquarters at ramsey
solutions studios so thrilled that
you've joined us triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
jump in triple eight eight two five
five two two five and i look out on the
debt free
stage in the lobby and i see alex and
katie welcome
hi thank you yeah where are you guys in
from we're from provo utah area
utah all right go cougs
there we go okay big football fan like
that i like that a lot okay you're here
to do a debt free stream so let's talk
here how much debt did you pay off okay
are you ready for this
about six hundred and forty thousand
dollars whoa
and i see you got two kids so i'm
assuming you
sold a couple of them yeah yeah the
other two aren't here but we have four
two are with us today so far wow all
right how long did it take to pay off
640 thousand dollars about 12 years 12
to 13. 12 to 13 years okay what was the
range of income
started out about 80 and
um ended up at about 145. okay nice i
always love to hear this story because
i'm so is this your house
this is oh i'm sorry i dropped the gun
yeah hyperactive guys he's got a tie on
for the first time today and it's choke
of the opponent
that's great so i'm just curious what
what did you do to to go from 80 to 140
k was it just good old-fashioned
promotions what happened
well um
my husband has been self-employed for 25
years and um he started
working for
the local university and also ran his
his part-time now job yeah and i have
worked part-time
as an audiologist and then recently
started being an adjunct professor also
well at the same university oh look at
you guys and working a ton of overtime
for both of us i'll bet well way to go
all right john now you got the call so
was this your house too
this was not only our house but three
rental properties oh my gosh so we're
feeling very light it's wonderful you
guys are quadruple weird if you're doing
the math right
that's amazing we couldn't be more
thrilled yeah wow so the 640 was in
totality all of the houses yes are all
of our mortgages and all of our consumer
debt oh that's why i look so light it's
like
i know we had to tell you to duct tape
your feet for this thing oh my gosh so
what happened 13 years ago that somebody
sat down and said we can't live like
this well we were on our date we went to
a play and during intermission we
started adding up our debt
uh i don't know if that's normal but
that's what we heard at all but go ahead
we're not normal
that play must have been terrible no it
was actually really good but but we
started doing it on a napkin and we got
so sick we didn't even stay for the rest
of the play we had no idea how much that
we were in no clue wow until we started
jotting it down that night and it
physically made us sick we had to leave
i was going to throw up and cry and so
we left
and i threw up and i cried oh my god
goodness so so what did gazelle
intensity look like when you come home
and you begin to figure out the plan how
did you enter did you did you interact
with dave the dave ramsey show what the
the book what what was the guide it was
actually we feel
like divine intervention the following
week after that we were going on a road
trip and i went to just look for a book
that we could read on the way and i
found the total money makeover
and i had never heard of it never and
i'm like oh this this looks interesting
so i bought it
and we read it um on our road trip
front to back and we've never looked
back that is phenomenal wow so what were
some of the big changes you made
what changes didn't we make
yeah we stopped spending more than we
earned that was a big one we started
budgeting
um we started teaching the financial
peace university class we did that
multiple times that was a huge because
when you're teaching it you actually
have to live it isn't that the truth
yeah yeah
um yeah we just
really were careful
and
yeah so i got to ask john how old were
the kids uh because i see them out there
those two of the four yes how old were
they when this journey started my oldest
when we started was almost 13 and she's
26 now okay and the youngest was two and
he's 15. he's 15 now oh my goodness so
all you've known is austerity and
and parents with a plan that's
incredible yeah we were laughing when
you were talking about all the bacon
eating and stuff because
yes oh yeah i could tell that young man
could put some bacon on he does sure i
get that oh my goodness so uh was there
a point
in the 12 almost 13-year journey
where you felt like okay we're we've got
some real momentum now because this is a
lot we're talking about four mortgages
that's a big mountain to scale
talk us through that journey what was
that moment or maybe uh you know a mile
mark or where you went okay now we feel
like we're running downhill i don't know
i feel like we had many of those when we
first paid off all of our consumer debt
before we even touched our personal
mortgage that was a huge boost to us
like wow we just got through baby step
two
you know wow
we can do that thousand dollars yeah
like that's a lot of money yeah wow and
so once we did that we're like oh my
goodness we wanted to come then we're
like oh no let's get the house paid off
first and so we worked towards that well
as soon as we get our house paid off
we're coming
and then we paid off our house and that
took years we still felt like we had
this debt though with those rentals yes
and we were still motivated saying like
we can totally do this
and we're like let's get the next one
paid off and then we'll go wow and then
we got it paid off and we're like oh my
goodness we can totally do this yeah
let's let's finish baby yeah and we
finished what
driving the old cars and the old
furniture all these things just to keep
motivated
what advice would you give to couples we
took a call yesterday um george campbell
and i and they were talking about how
scary it was to look down the road and
see a two-year payoff date
you guys did this for a decade you did
it for more than a decade what advice
would you give to couples who were
staring at their debt they just added it
all up they just got that sick stump
feeling in their stomach one of them's
throwing up in the bathroom right what
would you tell them
about going on this journey together
well one thing is they are baby steps
you don't have to eat the whole elephant
in one sitting
it's one step at a time and that made
all the difference for us i mean we
could you know immediate results with
baby step number one i mean that was
fast so just the baby steps they're
called baby steps for a reason
and that's what got us through and
having your partner on board i don't
know how some of these people do it that
don't have a spouse that really helps
them you know to be on the same page so
you're not having to say no we're not
going out to eat because you know
things like that when the spouse agrees
and you can actually put off things
that you can say we'll get later or do
later i love it so i think people want
to know i know i want to know what are
these four houses worth now
well the housing market in utah like
everywhere has gone bananas
and so
i'm not exactly sure
ballpark
probably close to about 2 million
watch out we have everyday millionaires
oh easy baby step millionaires easy that
is so cool wow boy that's why you're
that's why you're so light alex i mean
you're practically we have to tie you to
the stage just to do this debt free
scream well that is so awesome you guys
represent
uh what i think is that this is
long-term thinking
and that led to those baby steps the
discipline and just staying with it now
you sit so pretty you're still young you
got great kids their life has forever
changed as well so fantastic hey what we
want to do for you uh we want to give
you two books uh to kind of just show
our love and appreciation for you and
model in this way uh first is we're
gonna give you dave's uh book the legacy
journey because that's the next step for
you this is all about impact and legacy
for you all now and then we're gonna
give you a brand new copy of total money
makeover for you to give to somebody
else and bless them because it worked
for you and so we want you to pay that
forward all right let's do this we're
going to get the kids up there i know
okay so we're bringing up madeleine and
aj all right and aj's 15 madeline how
old is madeline madeline is almost 23.
almost 23. well look at the smiles on
that family's face really good stuff all
right let's do this thing alex and katie
madeline and aj from provo utah they've
paid off 643 640 000
in 12 years making 80 to 145k
let's hear your debt free screen
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna have to get that looked at
during the break doc are you qualified
to do that she's an audiologist she's
amazing that is so guttural because that
is the end of a journey where they just
cross the finish line emotionally i love
that what a great family wow all right
folks that's why we do the show right
there don't move this is the ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsey show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by dr john dolone my
colleague where ramsay personalities and
we are your
hosts this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's the number
to jump in triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to san diego
california where krista is staying
classy i'm guessing krista how can we
help
hi
so i just turned 25 and i inherited
about 128 thousand
um from my mom
um and my husband and i are on baby step
three uh the emergency fund we're about
halfway through it um
our goal is twenty thousand and we've
got about 9.3
and so i'm wondering if i should take
out of my inheritance for completing the
emergency fund or if i should keep it in
the fund that it's in right now what
kind of a fund is it in
um it was a
trust fund um that
opened up when i turned 25 um so now
it's in an individual account okay
well i
what i want you to do is uh is i want
you to get with one of our smart
investor pros out there in san diego
california area because there's there's
more to this than just you know
completing your emergency fund but yes
um i would make sure that you uh talk
with them
and figure out what you want to do with
this the whole amount so that we can
maximize this money now that it's
available to you and you guys are doing
great things but yeah i would definitely
complete the emergency fund and then uh
you know if you guys are if you're
planning to uh do you have kids did you
mention you have kids yes or no
um
okay so right now the college fund you
know
i you know you don't have to worry about
that per se but i just want you to
maximize this money but yes i think the
simple answer is yeah let's go ahead and
complete that emergency fund and keep on
walking through the baby steps that's
just fantastic hey krista where did your
mom pass away
um when i was 19 2015. 2015 and so oh so
you just turned 25 and so the trust
completed itself
yeah yeah your mom pretty awesome
she was yeah
would it would it
honor her to know that you had been on
this debt-free journey and that you have
the financial security of an emergency
fund would that bring a smile to her
face
i think that it would yes yeah
um
to be
comfortable
and
to
not worry about money and
so i don't want to mess up and do
something that she wouldn't want me to
do with the inheritance no
just making sure i educate myself and do
what
what's best for it yeah you're so wise i
i
love the idea of honoring
your mom's gift with this idea of
security and stability i think that's
awesome yeah absolutely and so that's
what you do um i want you to
uh to make sure that you again
play the baby steps out all the way play
the playbook and mom would be so honored
by that and you still got a good chunk
of inheritance to maximize absolutely uh
after you just do uh what amounts to ten
thousand dollars out of that very large
sum so krista don't have any question or
guilt about that but sit down with a
professional says you maximize it and
when you do this i john i love the
approach there it's like you know mom
gave you this money she was an amazing
lady and so maximize it yeah be a good
steward and maximize it and uh what a
great way to honor your mother love that
uh i love that let's go to saint
augustine florida where rich joins us
rich how can we help
i'm not too bad how are you sir we are
having a blast
well i wish i could say the same uh
uh-oh what happened what's going on yeah
trying to keep the spirits up okay well
i'm in the car business and uh oh
a lot of changes in my life recently
i've been divorced the divorce cost me a
lot of money
um
i ended up moving from connecticut to
florida
was doing very very well down here and
ended up getting cash app scammed
for 15 000
right out of the account which brought
me down to five
and
it was pretty tough to deal with that
[Music]
i ended up moving back up to where i am
now st augustine getting a car sales job
up here doing very well and now we're
running out of cars yeah
yeah and i don't know what to do um i
i have obviously terrible credit i had
to go through a bankruptcy uh there's a
long story to go with that but uh
that happened so
not a lot of debt at the moment um but
not a lot of savings
not
not making close to
what i used to be able to be so what
what was your income give me an average
range of income before the uh the hit uh
to selling cars with this low inventory
what was it before it slowed down
so it varies but uh i would say i was
making
per month
i mean we do get paid per week but uh i
would say per month i was making 15 000
yeah yeah what's the forecast what are
your what are your leaders telling you i
mean because they they're they're having
to react just like you are but what's
the forecast on this what are you
hearing
nobody knows okay well you know i'm at a
store right now where
you know what most stores are doing are
loading up on pre-owned vehicles
and selling those
because the new ones aren't coming in
um
at a higher rate and and
you know our store's not really doing
that we do have a pre-owned lot but
um you know there's not much in it uh
and i went from making what i was making
to making
and
we're talking four to six hundred
dollars a week
okay so you know so rich
so rich we've got ourselves an urgent
moment yes
yes sir okay but here's the deal i'm
wondering do i stick with the jihad
do i find another profession you got to
sell something else right now this isn't
even about
uh purpose or or profession we're kind
of going okay we want to get ourselves
stable okay you've taken a lot of hits a
lot of financial hits from the divorce
to the scam
you said you didn't have a lot of debt
but all of a sudden you got a big hit to
your income and what i'm thinking first
and foremost is you're a good
salesperson yes or no
yes sir then i would get after it we are
in a really good economy right now for
jobs okay and so i'm looking at anything
and everything that i could sell that
would get me in that ten to fifteen
thousand dollars a month range because
you were making 15 at your high and so i
think if that the you know the roller
coaster of car sales i think 10 to 15
you'd be fine correct
correct then i would get after that i
think this is an urgent situation and i
think you hanging around at the car lot
wasting away emotionally is what i'm
concerned about john i'm concerned about
that i want him to get healthy
emotionally but he also needs to kind of
get the financial stuff stable and then
we can get some healing so rich this i
love the little kid just said this is an
emergency
okay i want you to treat it like such
and also
step back 30 000 feet and look at your
life
divorce
about to lose your job
salesman you were bawling at 15 000 a
month and now you're making below
minimum wage
you got scammed all these things are
identity hits i'm a loser i'm dumb i'm
not who i once was i'm not even lovable
and that's all bullcrap it's all a lie
you're in a lull
and when somebody is struggling like you
are the key is little tiny wins
over and over and over i'm going to get
up at this time and i'm going to go
exercise i'm going to get up at this
time and i'm going to call somebody and
say i love you i'm going to get up today
i'm going to apply for three sales job
because i'm a stud salesman i just can't
sell things that don't exist anymore and
that's out of my control
you're a hard worker brother
you got a good spirit you're a very hard
worker i know you i you know when up in
connecticut i've been sales manager dude
hey
you're making great money you don't got
to convince me
what you have the person you got to
convince right now is you yep
i think you're right so i want you to
stand up tall stare down the mirror and
once you get on the phone the world
needs salesmen like ken says it's a hot
hot economy there's just no cars to sell
brother by the way you're already
trained so don't let this doubt creep in
well i've only sold cars that doesn't
matter you were selling solutions that
had an engine and four tires that's
exactly right so you've gotta you gotta
really transfer that experience and
skill set and i'm going to echo what my
colleague said he's absolutely right
rich this season that you're in is not
your sentence
you better make sure that you take steps
forward to change your life and it's
right there in front of you little wins
little wins little wins hey i want to
thank our producer ben hill our
associate producer kelly daniel want to
thank my colleague dr john delony and we
want to thank you america this is your
show this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car l studio this is the ramsey show
it's where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
delonia the phone number to jump in
this very important conversation your
future your life your contribution is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five to the phones we go
elisa joins us now in denver colorado
lisa how can we help
hello ken i was originally calling for
you um but if i think seriously about it
i think it might be a deloney question
oh i promise you it's a combo whether
you wanted it to be or not
so i have a job opportunity and
it's the same job i do now
um which is what it is
i'm in sales i sell science and graphics
kim actually called your show two months
ago you told me to take the job it was a
different job take the job but it wasn't
a money move so i didn't do it my boss
gave me more money
now i have another opportunity for even
more money
seventeen thousand dollars more
just on the base salary the commission
structure
is another
six percent better than my current job
on paper it is the right thing to do the
the healthcare package is better the
401k package is better i mean everything
is better um
i ghosted this company who pursued me
back in july i i just i didn't show up
to an interview and then he reached back
out conversations are going again
um
he thinks i'm i'm the right fit even
even though i showed to be a terrible
employee during the interview process
um i am so apprehensive i cannot pull
the trigger i cannot make the decision
so that's where john delaney comes in
well before we get to john i want to go
and pull this thing apart well no we're
going to we're going to work on this
together but i do want to go back to the
you said you called my show two months
ago and i told you
to take another job which means leave
where you are now why did i tell you
that i don't remember the call give me
the quick version sure yeah so it was
it's the same ex before it was the same
exact job for the same exact company but
it's a franchise it would have been a
different location it wasn't a money
move
um
they're
ultimately i mean the issue at my at my
place of employment you know i want i
wanted to own one of these franchises
one day and the
i was when i was hired it was understood
that they would train me and mentor me
throughout the process to become a
franchisee right and they helped
and and and they and they haven't so i
told you so i'm just trying to get
caught up really quick and so i told you
take this other opportunity where
there's a ladder is that about right
that is correct because that's what i
would tell anybody who called in okay
great so
okay yeah and so yes let's get to the
apprehensive stuff um
what are you so afraid of
name it specifically
so
specifically this job is set up
different everything is done third party
i'm more like a graphics broker and less
and less like a sign like where i work
now we make everything in-house we work
directly with the customer what are we
working directly with the customer but
i'll be giving what are you scared of
lisa what are you scared of you sound
like a politician like at a press
conference i didn't get a straight
answer elisa tell us what are you so
afraid of
i well one i'll be working from home and
i'm terrified of that i don't think i
have the discipline to work from home
great that's one thing what's another
thing you're afraid of
um i am also the sole breadwinner my
husband is a stay-at-home parent
and i'm afraid the ramp-up period where
i start making commission will be too
great and going into the winter seasons
and christmas time
if i was on baby step three i would do
this in a second but i'm not i'm on baby
step two and i'm scared to make the move
now i feel like i'm jumping from the
ship to the dock instead of just
stepping over
and
but it's the same exact job
yeah yeah
yeah but i thought you said that you
there was 17 grand i thought the 17
grand was already there that didn't even
count the uh take account for the
commission
yeah that's yeah that's just a base
dollar it's 57 000 a year i make 80 now
so i mean if assuming that i don't sell
anything for a year then really it's a
twenty three thousand dollar paid cut i
know that i'm not going to sell anything
for a year i'm gonna sell stuff but
but just you know the first few months
okay so so hurry so let's stay right
there let's okay that's the monster
under the bed right okay other than the
stay at home and i think john i would
like john to speak to that because i
think there's some stuff there i think
you got to listen to that because i tell
you right now i could not work from home
no i just i couldn't but let's talk
about the financial piece let john
tackle the other the financial piece is
okay what would need to be true for the
first two or three months that we would
need to cut back on you know where would
we cut how would we adjust our budget
what would we do differently just to pad
that to where you're not in a desperate
situation you're just in a hustle
situation there's a big difference there
you understand what i'm saying
yeah but i'm in a desperate situation
like my
i went and got a different bank account
the other day because my other bank
account was
1500 overdrawn and i didn't want my
direct deposit to go somewhere i mean i
i am in a desperate okay well that's
breaking news to john and i so that
would have been nice with that one
well that's new and i mean and i've
never
the money stuff i've never dealt with
the money situation that i've dealt with
now i used to i paid off 40 000 in debt
and then all of a sudden i'm just like
screwing up royally
hold so i i actually wrote down here
monster
this has nothing to do with your job no
you're a woman who's scared to death
yes and
you are on a ship that you think is
sinking and you are looking for the
first place to jump off of and right
before you jump every time
whether it's your husband
your whatever
someone's holding you by the sock and
you're not jumping
but you got something going on at your
house that you're not safe or you're not
okay or something's not right
because you're i'm an alcoholic and i
have a gambling edition here we go
yeah yeah i mean i i'm i'm totally fine
with
admitting to those things and and i've
been praying about it and i've been
working on it and all of it is getting
better but i don't know if all honey
it's listen better before i take the job
at least it's not getting better you
you're in the whole fifteen hundred
dollars you're now you're now opening up
new checking accounts to go under in
you got a husband that's at home that's
not working
you're in a desperate mess
yeah so i'm gonna tell you something
right now he he needs to get a job he
has to
yeah but y'all wouldn't i'm i'm fine
with getting a second job i did that for
a little while okay so my dad died i had
two cars stolen you need to get a second
job get a job but you wouldn't you
wouldn't say that to a stay-at-home mom
i absolutely would yeah i would too i
absolutely would wrong answer
i don't know i mean i hear dave say all
the time like oh i love it when moms can
stay home but you can't but he can't
stay home you guys are drowning elisa
here's what i'm hearing i'm hearing an
addict and i'm hearing an addict who's
great at going to war
i'm not going to fight you ken's not
going to fight you
you need help
you don't need a new job
yeah definitely no you need money and
you need help your husband needs to get
a job you've got to get clean
and you've got to
have a season of peace
asap last thing you need is the stress
coming with a straight commission or a
heavy commission job stay where you are
a second job will keep you busy make
some more money hubs has got to get out
to work and you guys got to get help
you can do this though you've done it
before you can do it again this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john dolone
and we are taking your calls this hour
here
on the ramsay show triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to ryan in
des moines iowa ryan how can we help
hi guys thanks for taking my call today
i appreciate it you bet what's up man
so uh
my life was kind of upside down when the
pandemic hit uh things things were
upside down when the pandemic hit
um there was uh our my my house flooded
and then my family split
and then there was a custody battle and
then i lost my business and uh the hits
just keep coming and that was before
the pandemic and um
and the email was probably pretty
depressing to read but i'm just kind
i've got custody of my son and uh
and
just having a real challenging time
getting refocused
trying to find a new purpose in life and
while at the same time taking good care
of my son
um there's not a lot of help from
outside from family or anything and i'm
just having a challenge having a
challenging time
i'm running i'm basically my cup is
empty
there you go i don't know which way to
go are you running your own business you
working for somebody what's giving your
work stuff well uh the business i had
closed uh during the pandemic
and so since then i've been
doing some landscaping and stuff on the
side to keep the keep things going
um but that's not the direction you know
that's not the career that i want was
the business
was the business the career you want was
it the dream job no
no no it was something that i started
part-time while i was in college and it
turned into something bigger okay and
then it became yeah and then um how much
money were you paying yourself i would
probably still try to push to it but
since it closed i just
i'm thinking a new new direction good
well we got a lot to tackle here real
quick what was the amount of money you
were paying yourself i mean what's that
number we need to get back to
financially on salary
um
at least 50. it was just a small
business okay
um
you've you called the right guy you've
got ken coleman here yeah he is a magic
on well i listen all the time and i and
i read the proximity principles yeah and
i got about three i got three quarters
of the way through and i thought wait
i'm not clear right well here's what i
want to do i want john
john's gotta talk with you you've been
through
you've been through a 12-round
heavyweight fight and uh i want to
applaud you
for uh for staying up you're you're
hustling for your son
um what would you do
i think you've had a lot of time to
think man over the last three years
you've been taking some shots what is it
that you want to do
you know
i thought about i knew you were probably
going to ask this and i if i had a
choice you know i would wake up tomorrow
and i'd be on a plane and i'd be doing
an archaeological dig somewhere
no joke
i love it tell me what you love about
the archaeological dig we're going back
into something but let's just what do we
love about that
um
the history the
learning about different cultures
civilizations uh how we got to where we
are now
uh how we survived back then um
that that to me if i was gonna simplify
that kind of work that's a form of
research do you see where i'm going with
that sure digging researching you're a
guy you've always been that way yes or
no
absolutely absolutely love to learn yeah
well a couple things i want to i want to
fast forward the process for you i'm
going to i'm going to i want john to
come in on this uh on the stuff you're
going through but here's what we're
gonna do at the end of this call
i want to give you a link
and a code to my get clear career
assessment you've probably heard me talk
about it on the show
and i want you to take it
and then i want you to call me on the
ken coleman show and we'll dive into
next steps but there are some really
great clues there you're a guy who likes
to learn you're a guy who likes to
analyze what you're learning that
researching diving for answers i think
there's a tremendous clue there so i
don't think you're very far away from
tremendous clarity but i want you to
take the get clear career assessment
and then i want you to call me on the
show will you do that
absolutely because
because we can make up some serious
ground yeah but i want john i mean he's
yeah what happened to your
stuff
uh well we just
it's that's a good question um there was
no infidelity at least as far as i know
um it just
it seems like we just
couldn't make could work it out i i
begged and pleaded and
and she wouldn't stay so so i'm gonna i
want to walk through a few things with
you
and i'm gonna say i'm real direct but
i'm i'm saying it because i love you
okay
you bet
you lost your home
yes somebody looked you in the eye and
said i don't love you anymore
i'm leaving
right your business went away
and ken and i both looked at the
research that when you lose your job it
can be as devastating as as the loss of
a loved one
and the reason i'm saying that this
starkly you lost your home you lost your
connection you lost your purpose
is
brother you should be feeling low right
now you're not broken
the feelings of i don't want to get up
and i'm grinding out a landscaping job
i'm mowing yards to put food on my son's
table tells me you're a man of character
you're a man of strength
and you're gonna make somebody else
happy someday
you're gonna build a new home and your
son won the daggum lottery getting you
as his dad
and your body is reeling a lovekin's
analogy brother you just went through a
12 round fight
the nevada athletic boxing commission
will not let you fight for months after
a a heavyweight bout like that they make
you take time off because your body's
got to heal that's what you got to do
and so
think of this you were on a boat and it
was a nice one and it wrecked and you
and your son washed up on the ocean you
got nothing
and you started finding food you started
hustling and i want you to use this
opportunity to sit on the beach and look
at the sunset hold that boy who loves
you so much
and think
dude all of this can be ours now
you hear what i'm saying
yeah
yeah i'm proud of you as as a dad yeah
proud of you as a community member
and once you recognize you can see a
fighter on the ufc they'll open their
eyes after they got knocked out and they
say what happened and the referee leans
down to their doctor the coach leans out
and said brother you got knocked out and
then you got to go heal and then you
figure out what's next
and
i want you to acknowledge
the depth of the trauma but also
acknowledge the strength you are finding
and the path out of this you heard me
say it earlier in this show
little step after little step after a
little win after a little win and you're
gonna look up in one year and two years
and five years
and the sun's gonna come up you're gonna
have a home you're gonna have a great
job because you're gonna get on ken's
stuff you're gonna follow his principles
to a t he's got a brand new book coming
out i'm gonna let him give it away on
when you call his show okay if you call
the show he'll give you a copy of it
uh
in that sun here's what your son's gonna
get
he's gonna get a ringside seat to what
happens when a man gets punched in the
mouth and knocked down and gets back up
yup and loves and is vulnerable and is
committed it takes a little step after
little step this is legacy change and
stuff this is family tree changing stuff
got it
10-4 ryan
you're standing today
and i want you to hear something
you still have purpose you aren't throw
away even though
your wife walked away from you
you're not damaged goods you still have
purpose as a dad first and foremost so
here's the deal whether it's landscaping
or a little bit better gig right now
until you get completely clear on what
the path is because we're going to get
you clear with the assessment we're
going to get you qualified we're going
to get you connected we're going to get
you started on that path to what you
really want to do you're going to get
promoted you're going to step into that
dream job and all the while you've been
a great dad to this young man do you
understand what i'm saying you are not
damaged goods your purpose has not
evaporated you hear me
i apprecia yes sir i do i'm gonna give
you a little hack okay here's the hack
there's a neural circuit in our mind
when we talk to ourselves in i and we
language
and it activates our fight-or-flight
response when we start thinking should i
buy this what should i do what job
should i take it fires our body it dumps
adrenaline cortisol into our bodies it
sends us into fight or flight
when somebody else comes to us and says
hey what should i do about my marriage
we're able to answer that well you
should do this and this could be a jerk
why don't you try to help them with the
dishes because our brain has a different
circuit for dealing with them problems
so tonight i want you to sit down and i
want you to write
ryan a letter in the third person dear
ryan
and i want you to start with the words i
love you and man i'm proud of you and we
are you've got punched in the mouth i
want you to write to yourself in the
third person about what tomorrow's going
to look like
your body's not going to take off on you
and then tomorrow you're going to wake
up the sun's going gonna come up and
it's game on baby
i love it
ryan hang on the line we're gonna get
you a get clear career assessment kelly
i'll get that to you take it
do it
call me on the show and we're gonna get
that path going for you great stuff
you're a hero bro your best is still yet
to come this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney we're here taking your calls
about your life triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five if you've been paying
attention to the real estate market
you've noticed that the competition
between buyers out there is intense
i talked to a friend the other day john
said they put in an offer in a house and
they were one of 23 and all of them were
over asking price this is the reality
all around the country not just here in
middle tennessee and that's because
inventory is low when inventory is low
it means that more buyers buyer buying
rather than sellers selling it turns the
pressure up on everybody
and this is not a time to go into this
as an amateur
low inventory is here to stay to win in
this market you need a pro by your side
our agents our endorsed local providers
help you buy or sell they've got years
of industry success and refuse to
compromise your financial goals no
matter how tough the competition is
go to ramsey solutions
dot com slash agent
that's ramsey solutions dot com slash
agent and find a trusted agent near you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
25 offers man yeah that's true right
here in a local neighborhood where it
was a new house new construction they
were all excited about it
talked with their real estate agent got
the offer ready and then they found out
like within hours yeah there's like 25
more offers
and they were in the low range they
weren't the lowest and they offered over
asking
and so there's your supply demand not a
time to our point to be messing around
because you can get fleeced i mean you
really get in trouble big time it's a
bidding war yeah so anyway crazy stuff
all right let's go to new york city new
york the big apple lisa is there lisa
how can we help
hi good afternoon um i'm calling because
i
my husband and i just bought a property
in florida and we are planning to move
and we're very excited now i started a
business when my son was born i'm a
child psychologist and back then i
wasn't when i got my phd now
um and
i started a business that was child care
and it was supposed to allow me to stay
with my son
until i figured things out and then it
turned out into two locations
and a lot of great clients and it's i
just really really really love what i
built and really really love what i do
um and i have a relationship that i i
wouldn't be able to have anywhere else
for my clients but the point is
that i can't stand new york one more
second i can't be here
i need to get my son and my family out
of here
i can't take my clients with me and my
business with me my husband wants me to
sell
he wants me to just sell it we already
kind of ran the numbers and i know how
much i would get for it
but i have an emotional
attachment to my business and i also i
can't bear the idea of leaving my kids
um even though i'm no longer in the
classroom i'm no longer i'm just the
owner yeah so my my question is um
you know i i thought of going and
leaving a manager but it's just not the
same the kids are not gonna get like
right now i you know if they need
anything i jump into the classroom i i
know how to do assessments i i just make
sure everybody's doing well mentally
physically it's just it's what they need
and if i'm just the owner i've worked
for owners before i know how it works it
just becomes a business so
what would you do
dr lisa
listen listen listen i'll let john talk
to you about what the emotions are
because you're definitely and i get it
but but i think there's two stark
realities that you just laid out for
everybody
number one you you're if you keep it
open and you don't sell it
then you're managing from florida and
you're still going to feel all this
guilt that you're feeling right now like
the kids aren't being taken care of
because you can't pop in the classroom
and if you sell it to somebody else and
go to florida you're still going to be
dealing with that guilt so this is a
bunch of guilt doc i hear a bunch of
guilt i don't think you can make the
decision based on this i think you've
already made the decision to go to
florida and you know what it's going to
uh
yield in the cell and so i think john i
think she's just dealing with guilt
that's what i'm hearing yeah i'm like
lisa this is gonna this is gonna be not
a great analogy but i'm gonna get as
close as i can okay
so everybody listening apologize uh
apologies up front
so
let's say that um a mom brought in a
little kid
to meet with you
and
she um she'd gotten a divorce from dad
and she hadn't yet told the kid the kid
keeps asking questions where's dad
where's dad where's dad
as a child psychologist
you would look up from that sweet little
baby and you'd stare mom in the eyes
what would you tell her
oh my god um
well first i'll get to know the child
and i'll try to establish some sort of
connection but what would you do
that i'm there for her and that we're
going to try to make this work and that
i'm going to be there and i understand
i'm a mom and i understand what it is to
try to
give
everything we want to our children and
you know that i think she came to the
right place
one more step i maybe i didn't ask the
question right here's what i'm getting
at you would tell mom
that she's got to let her child know
that a divorce has happened
so wait we're assuming that mom didn't
tell i just that's what i said mom has
not told the kid yet
and the kid is asking where's dad
where's dad where's dad what would you
tell that mom she has no idea oh no
definitely yes this is a conversation
for mom to have yes absolutely yes i
didn't get that part okay so
you need to have that conversation with
lisa
oh my god
you've made your decision yep it's over
and the last person that wants to have
this conversation
with lisa is lisa
you know that you have to sell this
business if you were in florida you
wouldn't buy a business in new york and
try to run it long distance
that's what my husband said so
you got to sell the business you know
that and i think you have to be honest
with yourself about this one cool thing
you built an awesome business and you
helped
hundreds of kids and families yes
and you gotta grieve the crap out of it
yeah because that stinks but can i also
say you need to celebrate it yes grieve
that you're gonna miss this unbelievable
beautiful organization that you birthed
that served families well but and that
is grieving but also celebrate what you
did and can i also just say this a
little bit on the tough love side john
can cuff me for this on the commercial
break but you know what
you are replaceable
yes and if you sell it to a really good
owner they're still going to take care
of those kids and you're going to have
to let that go because the reality is
it's time for the next chapter in your
life
and there's a lot millions of children
that need help and support and love in
florida
do it again repeat the process
because you know what's really breaking
i this is my take
and john and i are friends i trust him
implicitly i don't even mind if he
corrects me right now in the air
i think
that
you're not so much grieving you're not
so much upset about the kids aren't
going to be served you're not
i think you're just really sad
to kind of walk away from doing this
thing that you really stink and love and
i think you're almost acting as if you
can't do that ever again and this is
goodbye forever and i think you're
missing the point that that work
that missional result that really makes
your heart break right now
that can be gotten somewhere else in
florida that's what i think that's you
that's exactly right is that fair are we
on the nose
it feels it feels overwhelming because
you know i did it and it was tough work
and i overcame so many obstacles it was
insane like opening a business in new
york is insane and everything was insane
and i overcame and i won and it felt so
good and i was just like yes and then
the pandemic came and put everything in
perspective
and i just felt that
you know i was like wow um it's both in
lisa it's both in yeah you did win you
did overcome you're a winner you're an
overcomer
yeah and it's time to go to the next
chapter yeah
oh i got an analogy
hey this sunday night tom brady's
walking back into foxborough to play
yeah against the new england patriots
you know what guy won seven trophies
susie six trophies there it was time for
him to leave cash the check lisa
hold your shoulders back you helped a
lot of families and a lot of young kids
but you know it's right for your family
and your life to move to florida and
find a way
to fulfill that mission in florida and
love on some families and build
something that continues the legacy of
who you really are lisa you're a rock
star so proud of it this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america this is the ramsey
show i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague and ramsey personality dr john
deloney and we are here for you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're just talking life
money
your work your purpose relationships
uh
that's pretty heavy stuff today yeah and
you know what
we're okay with that absolutely and
we're here for man i mentioned that
earlier and i just wanna mention again
we will change your name kelly's the
best in the business
we'll change your name your location
because we want you to feel safe and the
ability to be vulnerable that we're here
to just help you take some steps forward
so
uh trust me on that we'll do that and um
had somebody call in we should we shot
an episode of the john dolone show this
morning and somebody called in and
found out they had hiv and
um
just
couldn't catch their breath and their
parents had found out in a really odd
weird way and
i asked who you've told
and
the person said you yeah and i got
nobody and um unfortunately especially
last 24 months that's 18 months we've
just found ourselves completely isolated
completely alone not a lot of places to
turn and
um
but that's been happening for years and
years before the last 18 months it's
been revealed but
um
man if you find yourself
i just don't even want to turn that's
what we're for that's what we're for
yeah you know and i'm so glad you said
that john that's our heart and dave
ramsey did it for years we do it every
day here but i just want to point that
out
because nobody has to know your name and
where you're from if they've got some
voice analyzing whatever but i just want
you to feel safe
that we're here to help you and we will
steer you in the right direction if we
can't give you something on the air we
can find it and we are wanting to help
you so i just feel like there's somebody
right now that's listening and you may
not know who i am which is fine you
don't know who john is maybe you do know
we are whatever i'm telling you
you need to call yep triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
joshua in albuquerque new mexico joshua
how can we help
hey guys how's it going how's it going
thanks for taking my call you bet what's
up man
um so i have a
question
um
my wife and i
own our own business um
and we've been doing dave ish for a
couple years
um
and we actually got to a point where we
had paid a good deal off almost got it
there and then when we started feeling
that relief
well
things kind of went back really davis so
um we're now in fpu we started that this
month
um
and
are
really going
um game on
and so
one of the things that we've recently
figured out
is that
i mean we've been using every dollar for
a very long time
um however
we're not sure exactly
are giving
um i
i'm under the understanding and and you
know i was raised in church so tithing
is an automatic thing
um however we've been doing that like
for september
uh specifically 10 right off the top
from the business revenues um and my
wife and i had a discussion this morning
to where
she was saying you know i don't know how
we're going to pay all this off if we're
giving away all this money
um you know when we could be using it to
pay off debt
so i guess my question
boiled down
is
should we be giving
based off the revenues of the company
um or
off of you know what's left over
after
off the profit i guess yeah well what
are you paying yourself each month is it
a set amount or is it fluctuate
um right now it's fluctuating last year
we paid ourselves 60 000 each as ceo and
cfo
this year is probably going to be a
little bit different we've had less to
actually
we put more into the business
um we put more into the business so
it's not quite as big
but we have a our accountant is actually
um a random certified or you know
random certified accountant so they've
they made it to where what we pay
ourselves basically pays our taxes what
they've you know estimated as our tax
payments plus our 401k payment okay but
you understand why i'm asking this i
mean let's let's be very clear we got a
lot of people listening here we're
talking about the biblical concept of
tithe is that right
correct okay so
you called us i mean i can tell you very
clearly what what our position is what
dave has said i'll tell you what my
position is on this but i mean since we
i don't want to get too much into
christianese but i mean there's this
concept of the priesthood of the
believer right and that's between you
and god but the bible's pretty clear a
tenth of your income okay so the reason
i asked you what you're paying yourself
as your income
that to me is where you start you called
in though is that what your belief is or
if you believe that you need to pay off
of what the gross revenues
or the net revenues of the company are
tell us where you stand at this moment
well
i think where and and where we're trying
to get the happy medium is that
i've always
believed that it was
10
from the from trump that's the very
first thing
that you
that you take out
and then from there everything else gets
paid and because my belief is and i've
seen it
happen in real world
is that that ends up
i don't know how the math always doesn't
work out upfront but somehow it always
takes care of
you know
mysteriously right so so here's the
point then and i'm so glad you shared
that you called two guys and asked us
our opinion on this and the reality is
is i think the bible's pretty clear that
you pay a tenth
of your income
what your company brings in and i'm just
going to make this example up for easy
round numbers if your company brings in
300 000 but you only pay yourself 150
000 i personally would if that's what
you pay yourself then i would tithe off
tithe off of the 150 000 not the 300
that the company takes in um and so
that's my position on that but again i
you know if you want to pay it off of
the companies or it's not like that's
wrong it's not like god's gonna go hey
you gave me too much and i'm a little
bit upset i mean there is tithe and
there are offerings and i think honestly
that's between you and the lord and i
think that's between you and your wife
and this is a marriage issue and if
she's kind of going hey i think you have
to sit down and go okay what do i really
believe there's want to
and then there is
have to if we're talking about obedience
here in a spiritual discussion do you
understand what i'm saying
yeah absolutely and i think where we
where we are right now is you know um
so we find places to donate and we you
know she
she made the comment the other day that
you know we donated you know whatever it
was 14 000 last month and we're eating
rice and beans and
it's well now let me just let me let me
jump in for a second if we're saying
donate is different than tithe or are we
saying it's the same bucket well um same
bucket with charitable giving we gave to
the church we had a couple of charity
events that we you know gave to um
things of that nature um okay listen but
joshua joshua i
kind of agree with your wife if you're
trying to pay off debt i wouldn't be
doing charitable giving no absolutely i
would be tithing
i would be tithing that's scriptural
that's what we believe at ramsay
solutions okay
but i would not be doing charitable
giving so i don't think it's all in the
same bucket you're putting it all in the
same bucket but that's i think your wife
is right rice and beans
and you're giving money to charity i
think she's right john so
i i like to find places where scripture
and science interact crosses over which
is interestingly all over the place
all over the place it's crazy how that
works
and all right
one of i think it's important to step
back and call out the obvious
um josh you're important to the world
and i'm glad you're here god doesn't
need your money
he's a big boy
there is
a spiritual
and a psychological and an emotional and
a relational
um
strength and submission and um
orientation towards gratitude
towards realizing this is all passing
through our fingers and you and your
wife are arguing over a math problem and
it's a spirit it's a it's a heart
problem
okay so sit down and don't starve over
charitable charitable donations or the
top line versus the bottom line give
your ten percent off of your income and
feel the gratitude feel the thank you
feel the this is just passing through
i'm holding i'm a steward of god's money
not
blow my marriage up over the top or
bottom line here
good stuff joshua work this out hey i
want to thank ben hill our producer our
associate producer call screener kelly
daniel my colleague dr john deloney and
you america this is the ramsay show hey
it's kelly associate producer and phone
screener for the ramsay show if you
would like to do your debt free scream
live on the show make sure you visit
theramsieshow.com and register we would
love for you to come to nashville and
tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague dr
john delony and we are here for you this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five it's a free call triple
eight eight two five five
two two five thrilled to have you with
us uh you hear us talk about this all
the time on the show you've heard dave
say it a billion times
everybody needs a will and it's true
it's a basic adult responsibility and
there's no excuse not to have one get
away there you go you heard it from the
good doctor there um and uh you've heard
us recommend uh an online will is the
fastest most cost-effective way to get
your will taken care of we do get a lot
of questions asking if a simple online
will is right for everyone and we
understand that what if you need a trust
or a mirror will what kind of powers of
attorney do you need those questions
are
legit and if those are on your mind our
team has built a quiz to help you find
the right options for you you'll get
custom results based on that basic info
like if you're married or single where
you live and even the size of your
estate then you'll know exactly what you
need for your specific situation take
the quiz
by texting the word quiz to 33789 text
the word quiz
to
33789 and we'll also text you back a
promo code for 20 off of your will with
our ramsey trusted provider so get clear
on what you need and then get a discount
to actually get it and if you're
wondering by the way i got my will
when i moved to tennessee i
redid it here in tennessee yep using our
product that's an online will
so if you're wondering is this gonna
keep my family safe who would ever use
this i did
i'm trusting my family and my family's
future with that will yeah absolutely
right don't overthink it if you need to
trust that's a whole different thing but
that's what i needed that's what i got
and i'm good to go yep absolutely okay
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number let's go to kyla now
who joins us in boise idaho kyla how can
we help
hi i was calling um so my situation i
don't know if you guys have i just
started listening to your guys's show
i'm 33
a single mom
and
i my daughter passed away back in
december
she was in an accident and
we got
an estate
for her and
i've paid off on my debt i don't have a
car payment i don't own a house i am
renting right now
but i have
helped out some family members
and i have about 150 000 left and i just
want to
be smart with it um
i have other children
and i'm just not sure i've never had
this amount of money before
yeah and
i just started working again i didn't
work for most a year just from the grief
i was going through sure um
but i'm making
sorry
i'm making about 13 an hour
full time
and so
um i just
really want to
be smart with my daughter's legacy you
want to honor that baby girl huh yeah
yeah
how old was she when she passed away
she was four four what was your name
cayenne
cayenne like the pepper yeah
was she was she spicy like the pepper
yeah she was a mess huh and that's
something wow
yeah and she was
all for god and
she
you know
the last things we ever found of
hers was videos of her singing waymaker
she recorded herself and it was like
little gifts that she left us and
and it's just really been weighing on my
my heart that
i need to seek advice and i need to um
do what's best for
my family's future and like i said i've
i've helped out others in my family
um with the things that they couldn't
afford you know
because i was finally at that point
where i could do it and i wanted to sure
and
um but now
you know things have kind of settled
down
and i just
um
i want to
do something smart with it but i just
feel lost sure
well kyla um
this is uh
incredibly heavy stuff and and just um
my heart's broken for you yeah can i
just say i got a five-year-old little
girl yeah it's unbelievable her name's
joseph yeah and um
i don't have a picture of my world
without her
and um
i've sat with another a number of moms
in your situation and i can't i can't
wrap my head around it
so i'll tell you that yeah ken and i are
heartbroken
with you and um i want to thank you for
your bravery for calling today yeah kyla
i got to tell you something i'm sitting
here and you talked about the waymaker
and i just can't get the lyrics yeah
waymaker miracle worker promise keeper
light in
[Music]
there is a way forward
um
we'll get to a couple of items here
first and foremost you're renting right
now
uh 13 an hour job are you doing 40 hours
a week is that a full-time job or is it
part-time yeah i could work more than
that they said if i wanted to but i just
um
i get a lot of guilt um being away from
my kids longer than that because like i
said i am a single mom
how old are the other kiddos
oh man
so i have a 14 year old 13 year old 12
year old
an eight-year-old three-year-old and a
two-year-old
oh my gosh we're talking to the real
life wonder woman exactly
yeah
wow yeah and so she was like
she was the third to youngest
and um
really hard who watches the kids yeah
you have support yeah who what's your
support system to watch the kids when
you are working
my sister-in-law is a stay-at-home mom
yeah so she keeps my two little ones and
then my other ones are at school yeah
well couple things here john i mean
we'll tag team is really quick
kyla i
i i love that you're kind of getting
back out there a little bit um you've
been through unspeakable grief and i
know there's still probably a lot of
healing to do
um i i want you to get with one of our
smart vester pros i know you're brand
new to us so in just a moment kelly's
going to really connect you further we
want to make sure you sit down with
somebody that's a professional that can
say okay we got hundred fifty thousand
dollars and we want to maximize this
okay but right now you're renting so at
some point i think we need to look at a
home don't you think and and and yeah
that's where i'm stuck because that's
really what i wanted my next move to be
but with this housing market right now
oh i got you 150 000 is nothing
we're not having you jump into it john
yeah it's a solid garage hey uh kyle
let's do this um
if you've got a few more minutes we're
about to run into a break
and i want to hold you over the break
and
there's several things here i'm going to
walk through step by step with you
you've been brave and you're going to
help millions of people who are going
through seasons of loss right now across
this country and we're going to walk you
through a few steps financially
interpersonally relationally with
counselor and we're going to get you
plugged into some of our resources hang
tight we'll be right back this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
fifth
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
all right folks welcome back to the
ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague dr john delony and just before
we went to the commercial break
we got a call from sweet kyla
a single mom of i've lost count how many
kids a lot of kids
and she's just an absolute hero and she
shared with us that uh
a year ago she lost her four-year-old
princess
cayenne cayenne who had the personality
of a cayenne pepper she told us which is
so beautiful
and she lost uh cayenne in a accident
and so she's received a large chunk of
money she helped out some family and now
she's got 150 000
to
invest to use and she wants to be
careful with it obviously she wants to
do the best with it because it is
certainly something that is uh got
cayenne's legacy all over it so that's a
pretty heavy deal and we wanted to hold
her over and keep helping her out and
help steer her in the right direction so
kyla you're back with us dr john
delaney's going to take over to start
um okay kyle two quick questions um
where's where is dad in all of this
um dad is in oklahoma okay um is he so
he's out of the picture
yeah i mean respectfully he knows that
he's messed up okay you know because he
wasn't involved
in her life at all and
and so he knows
where he stands and
um he's
just trying to do better himself you
know yeah and um
but he's not in the picture though
no he's not okay um the second question
i have is is
is this is new money
you didn't have a lot of money before
this am i
right so
i grew up with a single mom um
my dad wasn't around or involved and
never paid child support and so yeah we
were always pretty on the poor end and
then i became a mom
right when i basically became an adult
and it was kind of
the same thing for me and
we've always just lived paycheck to
paycheck
and um
so this is the first time ever in any of
my families
that are still living the lives that
we've ever had
an opportunity like this to kind of
turn things around i guess go how much
money have you give that to giving up to
friends and family
um after paying
i had to pay the person who helped with
the settlement and everything so i did
about 50 000. so it was a 200 000
settlement and um
the person that helped me i paid about
um
12 000 to because he paid a lot of
things up front for me as well that i
didn't have the money for at the time
okay
and i'm gonna i'm gonna give you
some wisdom up front here and then we're
gonna unpack some things okay
i don't want you to give any more money
to any more friends and family
yeah that's my plan okay
um 50 000
is a lot almost what i would say taking
advantages of a lot of a hurting mom a
lot
i also know it's
got to feel such like such a gift to be
able to take this settlement and help
people for the first time in your whole
whole life i know that feels so good
um
but i don't want you to give any more
money out you can do what you want
you're a grown woman you're obviously
strong and brilliant but my
recommendation is 50 000 is enough
and it's a quarter of this money and
we're going to move on the second thing
is this and um i'm gonna
i want to back out one of the things
that we when we get money like this we
start thinking of what can i buy right
now what can i spend this on and it's a
you've been in fight or flight for so
long
both from uh that's how you grew up and
then you went right into kid after kid
after kid and then a divorce you've got
all these children in your house running
around and then you go through just such
a catastrophic loss
your sweet brain is just trying to solve
the next immediate problem what's the
next diaper the next meal right it's
everything is immediate
and yeah that is the definition of the
cycle of poverty i don't even have i
don't have enough money or i don't even
have the time to sit down and think
because i'm off to my third job or i'm
just trying to get the next meal and
then the next meal and the next meal
so what i want you to do for the first
time in your life probably maybe not
maybe you've you've been taking care of
some business somewhere i want you to
back way out of this thing and i'm going
to hand this to ken
i want him to walk with you through a
dream you may have never had which is
what do i want to do
what would the greatest legacy what what
would it look like if i became a nurse
practitioner i went to med school or i
became a graphic designer or
what are the things that i could do to
stick my head up and
begin to hold throw my shoulders back
and say i'm going to take this
incredible strength i have and this
incredible
just this character i have
and i'm going to change my family tree
in a number of ways by showing my kids
how to work by um
taking them on a journey was i go to
school by trying to figure things out
they're gonna have to step up and do
laundry they're gonna have to figure
some things out on their own and then
they're gonna look up and say oh my gosh
my mom changed everything
right
so sometimes we think of i got this
money i want to make sure i buy the
right house or i want to make sure i
invest in the right way you may be your
best investment
right well i i aim into that i think you
are and so kyla you don't have to feel
pressure here but i want you to do your
best and i know you've been through so
much i want you to do your best to go
back to young kyla a time like john said
uh where you dreamed where you wondered
about a future that didn't involve kids
and and and and you know
just kind of struggling and striving
what would you do if you didn't even
have to worry about getting qualified
you didn't have to worry about even
getting the job you just would do it
what do you what do you wonder about
what's what's in your heart
um you mean like what do i love to do
like how to work like if i had got to
pick a career yeah forget career let's
go
calling i painted cars
really and
yeah and i really loved it
um
well
it was i was turning something they
would bring these old vehicles rusted up
vehicles in and you would turn something
from old to looking almost brand new and
you were good at it and it was
satisfying and
and hearing you know i'm
open and i'm not trying to sound sexist
or anything but when a woman is in a
man's industry they have to work a lot
harder yeah and i don't think you're
being sexist
at all i think you're being right on
yeah so so let's capture something you
are a creative person true or false
yes yeah i'm i'm also a choreographer i
choreograph dances for my church you got
creativity exploding out of you god put
you on this planet kyla to create and
let's also
find another theme in this what you
loved was restoration you got joy out of
restoration
it wasn't just the creative painting it
was
i was involved in transformation and
restoration is that true
yeah it's true it was my favorite part
is just seeing the before pictures and
the after pictures and look what i did
come on kyla
come on
listen listen that's what i really loved
and it's like and i have
this money and i would love to invest in
maybe like renting a a paint shop or
something like that now we're on the
right track now listen kyla let's just i
know you got a lot going on right now so
let's just suspend all of that let's
just be really really clear on if i
offered you a job today in boise in a
really great shop and you're making way
more than 13 an hour and you were back
to painting and restoring cars or being
creative
maybe you were choreographing and
teaching young girls dance i don't know
but it's that creative
restorative or that creative
transformative work right because the
choreographing is transformative too i
design something i teach it i see it
perform if we could transform you into
any of that type of work would you do it
tomorrow
yeah i would okay so here's here's the
one
here's the homework assignment i want
you to dream for a little bit over the
next few days
i want you to answer the question would
i go into choreography the music side
the dance side or would i get back into
the cars and restoration and i want you
to let your heart answer what's at the
top and then here's what's next kyla how
do i get qualified i'm not sure you have
to get qualified to get back in that car
shop but let's get back in it you don't
so here's what i want you to do i want
you to contact some old folks that you
used to work with and go hey i want to
get back in the game a little bit stay
on the line i'm going to send you fpu so
you can learn how to manage this money
we're going to hook you up with free
counseling here we're going to send you
the proximity principle and ken's career
assessment for free we're going to set
you up
kelly get her on my show next week too
or this week let's get a call in let's
further this phone call let's keep going
further on the steps you take to do the
work you were created to do thank you
kyle we love you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman i'm joined in studio by my
colleague dr john deloney and we're
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five five two two five come one kamal
you are welcome this is a safe place for
you let's go to robin now who joins us
in san antonio texas robin how can we
help
oh boy um
i'm really lost right now um
i'm a single mom
i have two girls i'm
47 years old
and three years ago i crushed my hand at
work and
it's not going to get better i'm not
going to be able to go back to my job
i have a lifting restriction of 25
pounds and
i've worked in fire and ems
my entire adult life oh
no you were good at it too weren't you
yes
i ran the streets with those those cats
y'all
amazing
but that's wired into your dna because
because everything is just crumbling and
i don't know what to do all right well
let's let's talk about the crumble first
what's crumbling
well um
everything i was able to do
i also helped take care of my mother
who's elderly
and everything was going all right and
then i got covered and with all of the
medications and everything was even with
insurance it was
a big expense
and then we got a water leak that i
didn't know about
and i have a 1300 water bill and i mean
it's just everything and i'm off and i
don't know what to do and i i'm gonna
i'm gonna let ken walk through this with
you robin but here's a word i want you
to take out of your vocabulary effective
right now okay you trust me
[Music]
yes okay i don't want you to say
everything anymore you said it four
times in less than a minute
you have some major challenges okay but
when we say the word everything our body
responds
as though we are
immediate rights headed right for us
you do have some major challenges like
sometimes i know it does i know it does
but one of the things that's the
greatest gift you can give yourself and
those around you
is to write these things down get them
out of your head because it feels like
everything and suddenly you're going to
realize it's four or five things they're
huge and you don't have the money for
them and you're going to change careers
all that that's big
but it's not everything okay
yeah
robin let's start with the income issue
what is your source of income and how
much is it
um
it's not much uh
i get um i'm about to lose the workman's
comp payments because according to them
i can go back to work
um
and uh very very small child support
okay so give me a round number what are
you bringing in right now
um about 900 a month okay all right so
we have an emergency as it relates to
that and um i i want to i want to dive
into something to get your head and
heart aligned really quickly because
you're going through it right now this
is really hard
what would you say if you were to pick
one word to describe
what you loved
about being an ems firefighter what what
was it what would be the word
um help yeah helping people there it is
there it is
so
i've given my entire life to service
other to help other people that can't
help themselves i get it now now we're
on to something so robin do you believe
that there are other ways
for you to help people who can't help
themselves that that are not limited by
your hand do you believe that
um i'm sure yes right so say yes
say yes yes yes yes yes robin
your hand has been damaged
it is limiting you in a
very
very clear area of service but it's not
the only area of service you have
experience you have skills
give me a skill
and experience where you go i'm
top-notch at this ken and it has nothing
to do with me using my hand take me back
to being a firefighter or an ems take
give me a skill or some experience where
you go ken i was a rockstar this and it
actually didn't require me using my hand
give it to me
um
i'm part of a
critical incident management team yes
yes i'm certified in that too
you don't have to use your hand tell her
john no you should you take people who
have just seen the worst of the worst of
the worst and you bring them in peace
and you bring them into the now and then
you help them you you point them in the
direction of the care they need and
robin if it happened right now in the
midst of your pain if you were on a
driving along and something happened
could you not step out and take over and
be world class at it
what we just described
yes yes i know so robin
those folks who say you can return to
work i know you think they're bad guys
for saying it but they're kind of the
push you need right now because you can
you are experienced
and you are skillful yes or no
yes
now say it better than that that was
come out i was pathetic robin you are
skillful and you are experienced yes or
no
yes there we go
now robin listen a few people in that
i've run across are more of a gang than
fire ems you're missing your gang aren't
you
yes yes you miss your gang
those what a tight-knit group of men and
women who run the streets at night while
the rest of us are sleeping taking care
of stuff that we don't even know is
going on that's your gang and you miss
them in your soul
but also it's not a reflection of your
inability to go make
make good in the world
in another area all right so robin we're
trying to accomplish a lot real quick i
want you and john to brainstorm together
i'm going to facilitate you and john
cause you and john know this area better
than me no i'm serious i don't have the
knowledge yeah so here's the deal what
can she what are some jobs that are
related to maybe in that space
that she is qualified for right now you
ready robin go
nursing dispatch counseling critical
care debriefing
social work what else
what do we miss robin
i don't
med school law school
all right so now robin
some of those some of those answers seem
intimidating
we're not we're what we're trying to do
here is get your head going wait a
second i am not damaged goods i am not
done i'm as valuable as i ever was it
just means i gotta pivot and get in a
different space robin i'm feeling the
juice are you feeling the juice robin
i'm trying i know listen now robin
you're getting a crisis so what we got
to do right now is we got to get a job
we got to start working two jobs that
don't require you to use your hand i'm
not being insensitive i'm just calling
it out are you with me robin
yes 900 a month is
is is poverty level you're more than
that you can make money you must go make
money and while you're just getting
stable with getting some income coming
in and paying off the water bill and all
the things listen to me you're
reconnecting with the tribe that john
just talked about because that tribe
loves you that tribe knows you and that
tribe is connected and they can help
open up some doors true or false
true true 100 true if you called them up
and cried on their shoulder what would
they do what would they say
they would be here immediately to help
me then why don't you ask for help
it would be really cool to have some of
your old gang come over to your house
you get the cheap beer and pizza that
those knuckleheads drink and eat and say
all right
we got to shake up the snow globe
love that y'all worked with me what do i
got to go do something and i'm gonna
continue to help people yeah so do i go
to grad school and become a counselor or
a social worker and some of them are
gonna laugh and be like honey you are
not a counselor you should we got an
opening at dispatch right now that's
gonna pay 42 000. we got you hooked up
or we need someone to help fix the y or
the z or the a or the b whatever it's
going to be and that team is going to
walk with you
yep you're lonely and you're exhausted
and you do have some real money problems
you got to get on the hook on that yeah
okay it's both end call the water
department and tell them your story and
don't be afraid to cry to someone the
other end and say i'm gonna pay this off
just give me a little bit of time and
let's get back in the game let's start
making money your hand is no longer a
limit your hand is a badge of honor it's
a reminder that you
are scarred but you are valuable don't
you dare quit robin you got this i know
you do
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsey show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number to join in
today's scripture
romans 12 2 do not be conformed to this
world but be transformed by the renewing
of your mind that you may prove what is
that good and acceptable and perfect
will of god today's quote john carmack
focus
is a matter of deciding what things
you're not
going to do
hey kim before we take the uh go to the
next call um i want to circle back to
call we had a minute ago with kyla and
again she has a number of children she's
lost
a child in a tragic accident a few
months ago single mom dad's out of the
picture
and she we didn't get to it
but i do want to make sure we just tell
the audience
she mentioned she's really struggling
with going back to work because she
feels guilty being away with the kids
she has some family help and that's
tremendous that is what a gift that is
i want to tell everybody who is
working a
hour job or 12 hour job that's trying to
make ends meet and also has kids
and is stuck in that trap of i feel so
guilty that i don't have my kids
and so i and feel like this is all i can
do right now
and you get this on this treadmill of
guilt and shame and guilt and shame and
you get stuck financially you get stuck
professionally
what i want to tell everybody is when
you're clear with your kids
and they're able to go to a safe place
especially if it's for a season but even
if it's not for a season if this is a it
has to become a
i am the one who's going to stare down
the forest fire that's raged through my
family as terry reel says of financial
challenges of trauma of whatever it is
i'm gonna make be the person make the
change
your kids are going to feel it and see
it and be honored and blessed by it
especially if you don't live out of
guilt but you live and look them in the
eye and say mom is working three jobs
because i have to that's how much i love
you and i miss you baby with all my
heart and it is gonna cut down on at
times when some people are you're gonna
hear people at work saying i just watch
shows when i get home you're gonna think
oh my gosh how do you do that i have to
do laundry and bedtime and i just get to
read a book and i fall asleep in the bed
too
all of that stuff is worth it that is
generational changing work ethic and a
gift to your family and i know that
guilt is real but i want you to know
sometimes first if we i'm going to
school it's going to take four years i'm
going to miss a lot of games
but on the back end of that my kids life
is going to be different i want you to
lean into those seasons
and go full force and be honest with
your kids about it but don't not do
things and live and stuck
because of that guilt i agree i don't
think there's a more valuable lesson
that you could teach them than than the
many things they will observe
and and i think you're right the honesty
when you just tell them kids are so
adaptable when you tell them why you're
doing it they may not understand it at
first but boy oh boy you want to talk
about
cementing you're changing everything
yeah they'll they'll get home
yeah i'm glad you said that's really
good stuff triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number let's go
to boston massachusetts greg joins us
there greg how can we help
your challenge having a challenge great
all right guys thank you thank you my
call today
yeah hello what's up greg you're live on
the air hello hi thanks for taking my
call today yeah
what's up
uh so i just wanted to talk to you guys
um so i just uh recently purchased a
home with my new wife and um
you know uh we both work uh and you know
uh so
we're at baby step number two
of the um baby steps and you know we
have a thousand dollars saved and we're
now tackling debt spiral and
um
the through dave's teachings is talking
about how you should pay off the smaller
debts to the largest well um i have a
uh
no a zero percent interest on a um on a
thing i purchased a bunch of furniture
to fill my house
and um i purchased at 0 interest
and i have a higher debt at 18 interest
and i'm wondering if i should tackle the
lower debt first at zero percent or the
or pay off the higher debts
yes do it in order do it the right way
the reason that we teach it and i
understand you're thinking the math
you're going well i can't i got 18 on
this and zero here that's not what we're
making that decision on this is all
about momentum psychology it's yeah it's
the psychology when you pay off the
smallest debt you get the hit from it
john take him through it there's a
reason why we do that yeah
you're right to look at the math good
for you're right
you are
right what's gonna happen is you're
gonna knock out this furniture in one
month maybe two months
and then you and your wife are going to
high five each other and you're going to
take the money that you put in towards
that and you're going to roll it into
the next one then you roll roll it into
the next one
what you're going to get ken calls it
momentum it's a it's a psychology it's
all the same we can use whatever word we
want
we're playing a relationship game we're
playing a psychology game we're playing
a we're getting little wins game
what's going to happen if you try to go
look at the at the highest interest rate
it's going to be i don't know 7 500 for
the 18 interest you're gonna go one
month two months you're going to look up
and it's going to be 6 500
you've paid off 500 bucks a month which
is great but you're going to feel like
you're not going anywhere and the
temptation to slip back to go out to eat
let's go ahead and go on vacation it's
christmas time is too great and we've
put millions
millions of people through this plan so
it's not us just wheeling and dealing
and i know you're gonna be like nah bro
i won't fall into the thing just trust
us
put the math aside put your debts in
order smallest to largest and start
knocking them out one after the other
after the other after the other yep
trust the process number one that's
right but number two let that 18 percent
on that next level up thing let that let
that really dry
yeah that'll help you get through that
uh first one uh a lot faster let's go
don't buy furniture on payments oh watch
out don't yeah yeah bye
that's not even a depreciating ass
it's an asset in every st and every word
it's for your butt dude don't god
almighty don't put that on payments it's
a couch yeah that's true you're this is
coming from a guy who'd rather sleep in
a hammock anyway so now he's really
fired
let's go to hannah who joins us in
scottsdale arizona hannah how can we
help
hi good morning good afternoon you guys
thanks for taking my call
um i'm a single mom with one child that
just recently graduated from high school
and also she just turned 18 this month
um she knows what she wants to do in
career i just need to help
see how to help her
but emotionally yet because she's such
an introvert child
and not having cancer so um she's trying
to get a job right now
and just for the sake of having friends
i don't know if that's the right idea
and also encouraging her emotionally too
as well
um she's trying to apply for
scholarships to go to a university she
just started it um
a community college that i'm paying out
of my pocket for
and um she's not getting any scholarship
approved everything has been denied
since
becoming a little emotional for her she
stopped crying and stuff
joining guidance
what to say what to do i'm constantly
encouraging her but it feels like but
she's not seeing any results yeah it's
just it's made her sad yeah and that
said this the sadness is real um do you
have a good friend community that you
are connected with or are you an
introvert as well no
i'm not an introvert it's just that i
have
bad friends that i don't connect with
them anymore okay um
we're running up against the clock here
so i'm going to be real direct with you
because i love you okay
we can talk to our kids and sometimes
when we're sad we try to make those
cognitive issues as we can explain that
kind of stuff
kids
watch us
and if you want your daughter to learn
how to connect she's going to watch how
you connect with other people how you
connect with her
and so in this season was she still
living at home for as long as she's
living at home
y'all can have breakfast dates you can
do practice um
interviews in the living room the things
i'm saying are going to be silly you're
going to feel ridiculous and cheesy
at this point she needs to practice
relationships and it sounds like you're
the safest
person in her life she doesn't have
anyone else to do this stuff with
so i want you to download i've got a
thing on
at johndaloni.com you can download 20
questions it's just conversation
starters how to have conversations we're
actually printing up the cards take your
daughter out use those things and y'all
practice being in a relationship with
people again and she's gonna watch you
connect with your friends so go connect
with other people as well and reminder
rejection rejection's part of the game
it's things that are hurt it's not
personal yeah hey i want to thank my
colleague dr john deloney great being
with you pal i want to thank our
producer ben hill our associate producer
and call screener kelly daniel
but mostly we want to thank you america
because we do this show for you it is
your show it is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you